I know there's one you know there's only
one blockbuster left in Alaska yeah in
Anchorage it makes me laugh is it
yeah I didn't know there like I thought
there really it wasn't like I don't know
[ __ ] vice news or one of those kind
of shows and that all the people in
there like we just got it down to a
system we're just like our tapes and
then we like our tapes yeah like I ride
Alaska
I missed the porno section or knows a
blockbuster and dude they were such the
porno tapes were so thick like
everything else is normal sized porno
tapes did you rent pornos at video
stores yeah you could read porn I know
you good I know before the inner raiding
your neighbor's house there's always
some old guy that died in is just steal
porn give it to guys to beat up dudes
who are [ __ ] with me now people are
boring I used to pay man born used to
pay bullies and poor I go hey dude
here's some candy here's some porn that
dudes for handy yeah I'd feel like
lollipops there's some I'm so good at
stealing dude I was so proud there's a
lot in allowing pop aims targeted video
games from Target see that's what makes
sense to steal this guy's stealing
lollipops and Schindler's food say New
York dude you could get some real
ass-kicking going for some black jugs
okay I'm just gonna say people probably
wanted to beat you up till hey go beat
up that's a reverse effect I got a big
target on my back I got a beat off the
entire eighth grade class
I gotta fend everybody off like the porn
in upstate New York and like in [ __ ]
early 90s because the sam was like how
like uh pills are in West Virginia
things are like there's more pills every
person in West Virginia can have 500
oxycontin that's how many pills are here
take we need more porn yeah black jugs
Fox it was great man
probably Bush everywhere oh yeah fat
bush it's like early eighties early
early eighties when they would still
strip when it was just like wildfire you
know it would still score a porn like
there was a guy like a composer that's
like okay what kind of piano would go
good with [ __ ] eventually that
job just went away like there's one guy
who's scoring porns all over car like
that I mean and the winner for Best
Score is Davey insist on the one away
the [ __ ] movie tracks right I mean
you ever like scroll through porn and
they're like there's like some weird
music yeah that's too distracting uh I'm
out on the music that was somebody's
[ __ ] job I'm gonna watch this porno
and think about music I want to make a
move a naughty show sketch about that
about the couple that makes all the porn
movie music be really if you take the
time you learn an instrument and the
payoff is you score porn yeah I think
that's do you think people use air
babies and how to shoot porn if you
bought your house on there you could sue
it yeah yeah that's a good point yeah
yeah yeah you're gonna sue everybody who
ever stayed here Airbnb I mean once
you've rented Airbnb it's your $10,000
in damage Johnny look they do it all the
time you guys have you came on
everything I know
oh by the way you look up quicksand porn
this might need this turn into a video
podcast I know quicksand porn yeah you
go [ __ ] in quicksand oh look a
quicksand porn they're talking about
less it
yeah Kreischer talks about that he's
into it go to images don't go to like
oh there we go damn you blow my mind
there's nothing you have heard last time
like ember teammate it's like yeah
people like stop wiggling and grab onto
my dick I will drag you out of this no
it's basically just naked people singing
oh she's helpless those oh no she's
drowning a quick Sam I can't watch that
that guy's getting jerked off in the
corner hey hey go to dude dude freaking
out in quicksaves I got a TV show and
the guys like he's like hey you guys
help me and like nobody can help him
he's like a bro okay I said you mean
like he oh no Scott Oh son of a [ __ ]
somebody say Jeremiah Watkins what's he
doing no no oh my god man drowns in
quicksand and his cousin's like you're
dead hey Dave can't you hear me Dave no
go got our British host jumps into so
football it's getting the football what
is going on but I do today well can we
all agree the Raiders are just throwing
this [ __ ]
I mean we've been saying that since week
three they're just throwing it I just
think a little back up here doesn't you
really I don't see any way currently you
can justify that under melee no salary I
can they told him to throw the games
what I mean even the [ __ ] Dumb and
Dumber came out and said that it has
nothing to do with that was all him
which is even more scary it was dumber
dumber who do you think [ __ ] Davis
he's got that [ __ ] dumb and dumber
haircut
the worst haircut for a billionaire this
guy's got the worst hair title in the
world
that's what billionaires do is they get
bad haircuts and they bang tans and they
mock us I mean the [ __ ] out of here come
on we've already looked him up and his
wife is really pretty
of course yeah of course as well that's
a shocker no I'm just know that you are
completely superficial right your whole
species
no no she she thinks he's a sexiest
[ __ ] in the world she's gonna
have my dick she thinks that divorce
it's gonna be a sex scandal me to
movement oh you know he likes you know
when little kids when that's why you got
rid of Cleo Mac cause he wouldn't cook
his wife you know when little [ __ ] when
little kids have to eat broccoli or
something that they hate and they hold
their nose while they do it and pretend
that they make that that's what she does
when she [ __ ] his bozo she's probably
so high on pills oh yeah especially just
to [ __ ] him ah guys I wanted to talk to
you real quick about our good friends at
seeking oh this is the one that you were
teasing earlier you know no okay no one
I want to go about our friends our new
sponsors at the set bird calm that's
right semper calm that's easy
small travel size scent burn set scent
bird bird dot-com I was like I don't
want to bet that burn scent bird Dachau
one more time stay with me seventh bird
bird dot-com and what do you deserve you
deserve smell great who doesn't have you
ever walked by someone in the street and
think man that girl smells amazing
of course trust me I know how it goes oh
cool you get little samples of perfume
till you find the one you like yes and
cologne not just perfect but set Bert
scent bird calm keeps me smelling good
month after month that's right and it's
travel size they're very tiny and you
could take them with it on your flight
throw me your back when you're going to
a gnarly rehab to do well-crafted
multi-layered dick Joe just spray all
the patients I spray put it on your tank
keep it rockin man it's that that's it's
so easy we simpered has sent
burr
bird has 450 designer brands and you
could choose one every month Prada Gucci
Kate Spade mmm sadness nests and more
try exact exactly the brand you want and
it's the real deal it's kind of like a
monthly scent adventure
boom look at that I love it that's
that's a hundred-twenty spray so you
only smell amazing and your sponsors
everything you free [ __ ] what your
sponsors ever give you free [ __ ] now we
got some outside all right yeah oh so
you wanna give to the Parkin stores and
the pushy salespeople I hate those
pushing you ever going through those
make a place I hate you and if they just
hate you with all the [ __ ] and you're
like I didn't want that and it smells
gross yeah it's disgusting Oh silvered
no separ you get it dude that's right
that's why I always use set Burt calm
with this exclusive offer you get 50%
off your first first month today that's
only seven dollars and fifty cents for
your first perfume go to scent bird calm
slash punch-drunk and use the promo code
punch-drunk for 50% off your first month
that's s e s cen t-bird calm slash
punch-drunk shutting on smell amazing
come on dude get it look at that that's
our own page that should be our official
website looks like I like it our website
will be up in two weeks but the guys Sam
was auditioning for in that headshot but
he was making the face of the other one
in that this has to be hey white guy
smells so good you get hot black chest
that's what I said to me right that's
what that says that should be you and
Tebow yes what do you think she is
yeah she's black she's totally hot black
definitely part black no she could be
Dominican that's a guy from North
Carolina thinks anyone not white is
black
I think she's black and she's hot I
think she's Asian yeah
I know she ain't right dude I'm super
excited about this so thank you scent
burdock and that's good too the most
clones are like 50 60 bucks you get a
new one every month for [ __ ] I love
that I love that I guess like dude this
dude do you like Cologne that could be
like a sex toy to not like a straight
face no not if it's too much like I do
but not if it's you know some people
like you could smell them from here if
they were in the lobby like that's
better yeah headache yeah like Sebastian
did when you get a little like yeah not
everywhere you kind of got a not know
that it's actually on you yeah okay so
we gotta get some that they have it
upstairs but they're not here at each
other if we all have different sons I'm
gonna get a mic magic too two guys put
on their magic to like on their people
do that but I try to get a yeast
infection so please for all the guys
that might unbelievable the charges of
legit huh chargers look good I don't
know why man but I don't think the rams
are gonna do it dude what's with the
[ __ ] uh well losing Cooper cover the
year is a big loss for them because he
does everything I mean he's got six
touchdowns already and he's done for the
air he's on pace for like ten touchdowns
so sorry for your loss ram fans cooper
cut done for the season Chargers look
legitimate and what did you see the did
you watch a game Raiders game I watched
some of it I can't watch it
did you see [ __ ] car throw it out of
bounds in the fourth bound thank you
like it was first down he just do it
threw it away like at least throw it in
the field at least give someone a chance
to catch it dude you don't do that when
you're throwing the game oh yeah so
that's what I was saying before our new
sponsor came up was that
that was worth that he just throws it on
the ground
good-looking grins faces like you gotta
be [ __ ] me
yeah is that huh what's he complaining
about I think he's mad at himself why
did I do that yeah that's that phase
first half anymore I don't watch dude
this is a Raider fan I'm out that's how
I am with the Cavs right now
I can't I'm out I can't I'm not I I
thought there's hope but it's nothing
really cut at all time it is man that
was me 10 years with the Browns what
you're doing does need my entire life
with Arizona yeah I mean like you're its
it listen dude your owner our owner I
knew they were gonna be good for a while
because you guys got the new stadium but
now the stadium's been there for a while
so now it's like let's go back to being
garbage I personally think the Raiders
are throwing it so the Rams and them and
the Chargers can get LA I know I'm the
only one of the things that you're not
that bad you have you know you don't
train way everybody unless you're trying
to tank it to get as many number one
picks as possible which is weird because
I think they're gonna move Derek Carr in
the offseason maybe to the Jags
I think the jacks are either gonna go
after Derek Carr or even you know
Matthew Stafford I could see that
happening
going after either that move just
because they need next-level guy and get
another pick but the problem is there's
no good quarterbacks in this in this
draft coming out it's it's not three
guys that are touted by who
dude from Oregon to do from Duke right
out and then uh there's another guy
there - two guy from dude the kid from
Oregon
oh yeah up Justin remember is he good I
don't like running quarterbacks I don't
think any of them reliever them as
mobile I they came from West Virginia
that's the other guy I'll tell them that
are they tall yeah both son that's all I
want
give me Bo son if you can stay healthy
gimme ball so I could see that so
they're giving up on what's-his-face
ooh which means we could get Winston
first ah you don't want any of that I do
you do I do you rather have Winston in
car no but they're gonna get rid of car
until we can get a good quarterback and
Winston's your replacement
oh that kids tall take it height I'll
take them six six is good I'll take that
dude who is Cleveland yet let's take a
look oh that's who we're getting I mean
this is probably some [ __ ] 14 year
olds [ __ ] mock draft how tall is he I
still think Josh Rosen's gonna be good
he just has no line I don't know
I mean Mayfield's good May I think
Mayfield is legit
I think Mayfield could play both ways
you turned my [ __ ] yeah triple TD day
I think he's legit a kid from New York
to the audio portion of this podcast is
awesome hey hey you know you could join
us instead of just [ __ ] texting
people oh my god it's you coming from
you I haven't seen a - no lines
yeah Vinny Testaverde and now we have
the name of this episode Vinny
Testaverde look at that Oh Jarvis Landry
baby Wow
do you think there'll be any better next
year to Cleveland play a big time
yeah I mean they're doing this without a
head can you think they're gonna get
with that who do you think again as I
had you probably Jeff Fisher right just
a [ __ ] [ __ ] the bed well you know
there's a lot of rumors about them
getting [ __ ] the guy from Oklahoma
and now it does make sense now he's
claiming he doesn't want any piece of
that but you have to do that in the
middle of a [ __ ] football season
right right right
I imagine that has to be pretty enticing
yeah to take over an NFL team with your
[ __ ] fast quarterback you ever worked
are you at all in the college football a
little bit I mean dude there's some [ __ ]
there's some teams you're like Florida
State [ __ ] the bed yep I mean
[ __ ] the bed all three other major
Florida teams aren't good what about
Ohio State Oh House aide sucks Urban
Meyer's gonna he's gonna get the hell
out of it oh can we please talk about
that coach having a [ __ ] meltdown
Oh dude bring that up Johnny's been
trying to get him on the show I know
John is like I gotta get a hold this guy
so this is well pull this up who is he
so explain it yeah this guy now does he
not have a job Johnny okay real quick
this segment called Twitter meltdown is
brought to you by our friends at
SeatGeek
seeking for all of your ticketing needs
that's right go seeking calm or download
the app use the promo code punch-drunk
yep
and get $20 off your first ticket
purchase I've used them to buy boxing
tickets I have two tickets to the
heavyweight championship I thought was a
good deal $1.99 seems like they've gone
down a little can you look up how much
tickets are now oh they're not whoa okay
$60 on my heart attack dan was header
yeah get the app guys it's the best way
to do it get Lakers tickets going for
now then maybe they are they're really
expensive in the beginning and now that
they're like a 500 team like they should
be I'd still go watching on why I
watched him play the Clippers for the
first five years he was in the league
yeah you gotta see that you can get so
it's around what I bought him for I'm
real
Mays hasn't sold more if you get clipper
tickets early enough you actually get to
play in the game [ __ ] you buzz up look
you get Portland
Lakers 83 bucks that's not bad too many
concerts yeah let's have more people on
the show can we have more people on the
show please we're in the middle of a
sponsor dude guy so what Clippers for
$11 Sikhi go to Clippers go plink
Clippers you can get tickets for $11 no
Bret it's triple he's running his mouth
I'm dude I'm not running my mouth and do
the promo code for our cool sponsors
seeking seat geek go download the app
dude concerts comedy shows live events
poetry slams
Zane's shows in drug rehabs all here on
see cake man seeking what a deal what a
deal man total bust off you find
something I mean it's taken there's 16
bucks that's a free dude we should go to
UFC fight buy some tickets
alright so that was seeking thank you
see geek for being hour long listening
sponsors now all real quick let's go on
and find out explain to us what this is
so this coach is currently unemployed
from what I understand and I believe he
was a wide receivers coach or a special
teams cook what it was he wide receiver
coach at Ohio State and just starts
having this meltdown on Twitter and
pretty much outing
Texas's Coates right the Texas Texas's
head coach about cheating cheating on
his wife starts really spilling the
beans about some like read here's some
of like why don't you read them no
because Ari made me feel like I can't
read and I'm still know the show is here
on the show I think about it all the
time how do coach Tom Herman and Bethel
haba feel that's his wife that's my
feeling
underperforming season better question
how does she feel about her husband
being a biggest [ __ ] bag in America
doesn't want to ruin her own life just
like she told my ex I'm done being quiet
Michelle why does this guy care so yeah
so he's tattling oh yeah they're coach
for two years walk on Twitter because
this coach zachsmith used to be the
defensive back coach of Ohio State okay
and this whole thing came out they used
to smack his wife around and the coach
of Ohio State which is Chad
Urban Meyer Urban Meyer did not report
it or fire him
heard about it didn't do anything about
it and this guy thinks that coach Tom
Herman is the guy who basically told the
authorities about this or the NCAA or
the press about so he's in trouble so
he's bringing down someone else with him
hi coach Tom Herman which makes me think
that is that his actual handle probably
oh you usually you can click on it he's
still running you're okay hi coach Tom
Herman you still running from the truth
cool with me getting my life ruined on
some [ __ ] but don't want me to
expose you send one more person to meet
with me to hide your [ __ ] I'm done
protecting you [ __ ]
you're a bad human and even out like up
there's a he goes on a long I mean if
you follow his twitter which is I think
that's great I totally believe that he
was approached by some 60 year old
[ __ ] who was like trying to cover up
some bright guy with that mustache
listen here where I'm from we don't do
these exactly [ __ ] that however there's
several times you cheated on your wife
and then acts are at it she told my ex
about it do you remember that because I
do laughing my ass off he's laughing his
ass off was he already fired at this
point or this hey Murphy no he's after
this eyewitness Tom and cheetahs wife
several times once at an asian massage
part and i just text him that I'm done
protective wanna get wanna be honest now
or nah laugh of my ass
I love how he's talking like a 19 year
old yeah yeah I know so who's this coach
Zack Smith who is he coach he was Ohio
State's wide receiver coach okay and now
he's just throwing everyone under the
bus as coach Tom Hern yep
because he believes that Tom Herman was
the one that outed the whole Urban Meyer
and all that thing hey coach
Tom Herman remember when you told me
about Billy Nahanni cop yuichi honor
with an iron State recruiting girl ha
half of my ass off I do this guy's
[ __ ] burning them he's burning him
days burning it all down max including
Tex
Oh easy screen capture Tex uh-huh
you're the biggest snitch alive and also
the biggest hypocrite alive anyone want
to know all that I know about Tommy Boy
contact me and then here's all those
texts Breeden it says it starts with me
it says and never will be able to so own
your [ __ ] self because now after you
decide to ruin me I'm going to expose
you who you really are courtesy of
Michele and several coaches have reached
out to me to express to you because as
they said who is he to condemn you and
when he was living right god you're the
word he wasn't living right I I'm sorry
it's hard to see dude thank you for
coming in do great job ah
we'll let you know if we go I wouldn't
count don't hold your breath
send Courtney more money [ __ ] I'm gonna
share everything about you including all
the pictures I've taken of the [ __ ] you
did so tell Randall and all your cronies
to stop because I'm ready to expose this
guy beat his wife yes yeah no no no no
no he no he did beat his wife oh yeah
that's the guy like that all his
pictures on Twitter him and his kids so
he's coming off like a family man but he
really be it's them in fact well you
could love your kids and beat your wife
it's not mutually exclusive so Tom
Herman still on Twitter it needs elitist
cow
you can also beat your kids and love
your wife yeah that's true my stepmom is
from Ohio and loves Ohio State and sends
me
these all the time and makes me put them
on her on Saturdays and I don't even
know anything about all this does anyone
know who Gucci's you guys remember Gooch
from Vegas doesn't tell you how I look
like Gucci Gucci Ohio hook em horns it's
my stepmom so I don't even know that's
how much I don't owe family we actually
are close but I don't know don't you ask
is there more than one place at Ohio
told me sure when those ladies are like
stalks like non-stop so you kind of like
pick what you listen to go down okay why
are you boning this apparently anyway so
is this guy doing this whole thing to
get out of to get the the spotlight off
of him beating his wife no what it is is
his life he's been fired he's never
gonna get a job again cuz he smacked his
wife around so now he's going off and
trying to get this guy fired but he's
never gonna get him fired from Texas
because Texas is actually playing decent
now and like you just Texas football's
huge it in like Austin about huge in
average yeah in Austin it's crazy yeah
yeah the Longhorns are huge
you're never gonna [ __ ] with that I mean
dude penthouse got a penthouse Penn
State got busted [ __ ] dicks and they
did one football game not one I mean
dude things came out that the
administration was [ __ ] kids dude
Dean lose one game that's how big
college football is hey coach Herman why
don't you admit that you and Sam triply
ran a train on a black woman is that his
new one Chad why are you doing more cold
readings we told you we enjoyed your
first one and we'll let you know four
interest in work again dude Ohio's I
mean
da he pled guilty to disorderly conduct
after you smell I'd like to disorderly
conduct the [ __ ] out of my wife how is
your wife she dead hey the best
yeah so that's [ __ ] knots dude I mean
it's just college football there all I
can say but he's like supposedly like a
football genius
his wife's hot though you know she gets
transferred daughter ain't too shabby
either
she's she knows what's coming
yeah she knows where your bread is
buttered yeah good for him yeah when you
got money [ __ ] out of your league for
sure I mean apparently and I'm more so
out of your league that's his hot wife
and he's cheating on her I would love
her so right I would love she looks so
cheat honorable I'm doing a cheat on her
[ __ ] their commands oh that's when they
were at that's when they were at Houston
we've got done there kid looks really
looks like a dumb [ __ ] if that was my
kid I would totally cheat on and beat my
wife so let's let's power rank our our
NFL teams has who's going to who's going
to sue Pro whoo-hoo Superbowl yeah who's
I mean I have I know what I'm rooting
for I had Kansas City versus versus the
ribs the Rams pile think the Rams are
gonna make it I think should be Saints
versus jizz drumroll please chargers
I like charges rims that's what I'm
really rooting for I want charges Rams I
want to blow the whole system up both la
teams so why nobody goes oh why does our
own fan base one has I
semi okay fanbase and if the AFC
Championship game happens to be in that
soccer stadium that holds [ __ ] 18,000
people and it's a road game it's gonna
be hilarious no way we'll be there
oh it'd be totally packed its I'll be
all cheese jerseys that would be
hilarious you wouldn't have home-field
advantage waste would that be crazy and
then it's [ __ ] both la teams in a
Super Bowl that would be hilarious
that would [ __ ] everything up they're
talking about in the NBA there's a real
chance that the Lakers could take on the
Clippers in the first round how great
would that be
bro that would be that would be better
than the other can you imagine the NFL
[ __ ] their pants they just lose an
entire other market to have both those
teams in it no one gives a [ __ ] about
charges nobody gives just 53 people in
Los Angeles they care about the Chargers
and they are the Chargers yeah haha for
real
that's no joke I don't know a one
charger fan now I did know charger male
Hall that's it one like half black can
it still or is he like [ __ ] them he's
leaving for leaving because the charger
fans I knew I could see now Hall like
him cuz he lives in LA and he's from San
Diego but charger fans I knew we're all
you know like Ryan Hill who loved the
charges as soon as they left he's like
[ __ ] them yeah I think they I think was
a dumb move I think the the NFL
overplayed their hand and they should
have bought San Diego City Oh such a
great market it's just like when you're
going hey Cleveland
we need a new or Cincinnati sorry Chad
Cincinnati
we need a new stadium you got by force
elsewhere leave I could get that but
were you talking LA San Diego these are
like insane market there's more people
on the field than there are in the
stands they're expensive I mean we could
look it up on our seeking for all I know
Antonio Gates I got a hookup but they're
kind of expensive because there's not
that many seats and like every seats
like really decent
what we got here play that's another
thing like you're in a market where
nobody cares and you're charging a
hundred and forty six dollars anyway
anyone go they play at Fairfax High
School Hollywood High what are they so
what Kimberley sequence 145 I all the
twins go on Sunday when Johnny and all
of us went to the [ __ ]
Rams game it was like 40 bucks but you
were like way up high you weren't where
those seats are yeah but it was fun as
[ __ ] yeah the parking was a little
expensive I heard what you guys did
there you just like took over someone's
house like it was your own they were
nice though but it was $150 we were like
by the stadium to park dude that's our
ticket right if a ticket was 40 these
guys just fell up I mean they just fell
up what yeah now why was the fire alarm
going off that's the weird thing
yeah he just completely he's probably
gackt out on his [ __ ] prescription
meds he loves the [ __ ] by the way
nobody remembers that scandal we got him
busted for [ __ ] basically script was
he doing like he was making fake scripts
for more oxycottons or something yeah
the guy's a pill head right who Sean
Payton yeah he loves pills man like he's
kind of like sports man that's really
good maybe you'll be doing standing in
front of them sometime oh I've been in
front of some NFL players before really
yeah I can't say who or where I was but
oh yeah up and up in Beverly Hills oh
really in front of a lot of we know one
of them is Johnny Manziel without
question you know Nehemiah
I've heard stories about how Josh for
these sex addiction me
there's a lot of pro athletes and like
you know what everybody has a problem
with trans yeah they're all they're all
[ __ ] getting just addicted to trans
yeah because it's like starter wheels
for [ __ ] weirdness right you know
he's like hey let's put on some [ __ ]
training wheels oh here's a trial that
chicks hot with a fat dad I want to ask
you the whole the whole thing now is can
this college team beat this protein and
the whole thing was good Alabama beat
the Raiders no absolutely not absolutely
not okay the next one is going into
basketball could Duke beat the Cleveland
Cavs I think that is the closest
argument we've ever had out of all the
teams I don't think so no way they're
bigger they're all they're all eighteen
yeah Duke beat army by eighteen think
they're gonna be Indiana is they have no
score Luke dude go go to the go to the
Cavs roster Kevin Kevin Love is out
right now
here's the thing do all 12 people on
Duke go pro a dude goes all of them are
people they have a top three picks damn
that the top three picks in the draft
but to put the entire Cavs are in the
NBA right right
right there or just make it to the NBA
watch watch watch hey are we doing a
podcast are you guys just [ __ ]
playing touch but over there 30 people
on it are you listening to us you know
we're having a discussion
so go to the Cavs go to the Cavs roster
okay
so let's take a look oh who's a good
score on this team jr. Smith can score
he's yeah but when their plane bears
children they can all score
and he went 10th so you got Jerry Smith
you got I do it on the hood
I'm not saying Duke would win but this
is the closest to cat that conversation
has ever been I mean oh the Cavs will
words team in the NBA yes and we haven't
seen a college team this good in a long
time I said it to you on the phone
yesterday there I could put them with
the UNLV team that you loved okay all
right well you know it's a fun
conversation I wouldn't be willing to
make a bet you know where I'll make that
bet I'll bet des I bet do your side it
will take them all of your baby happy to
take your money bet DSi use the promo
code punch Utley 5 punch 25 and get $25
betting cash ah it's really that simple
Dew do the dew
football parlays do what else is there
Deb football's heating up basketball
college MBA women's Pro Wrestling I mean
it's all there for the betting will Chad
become a regular at The Comedy Store bet
on politics when he doesn't [ __ ] does
a get a showcase you can bet on politics
you can bet on award shows they have all
that there yeah you can bet it all and
that's so good that DSi bet the aside
use the promo code punch 25 that get you
25 free bucks to bet with win we'll go
over our picks of the week maybe get
some locks in I've been off the last two
times I thought you know I've been
picking winners but I haven't been able
to cover spreads but we'll give you take
a look at this week's schedule we'll
talk a little all UFC a little more so
that fight nanny can participate I think
it's like who's chiming in it's good
Chad might have to read it and also
whatever there's like stands here and
chimes in it's great whatever you put in
the doublet so keep that in mind too
so thank you to our good friends Betty
si let's go over the NFL schedule this
week and see if we can
Chapman Oh Johnny wants to keep
highlighting his neighbor stop with the
[ __ ] fantasy yeah some of us are
killing a fantasy so mister killing it a
life Johnny okay zip it some of us are
doing neither
[Laughter]
what are you doing chairs cleaning house
we're running a segment here stop France
Erlich let's see if we can get it with
the spreads this week I mean we couldn't
even look it up at our good friends
Betty isn't on the patreon yeah we're
doing patreon oh yeah we crush patreon
dog I don't go to punch smokes patreon
yeah look up the patreon Chum the
patreon real quick hang on Chris dude I
need people on my patreon no you don't
let's see what you got over here uh oh
my God look at that I look so good
you guys look like an 80s fan guys let's
look at more photos and not talk about
that oh look at that that's [ __ ]
badass [ __ ] I've ever seen I click on
the next one
[Laughter]
why'd you talk then oh [ __ ] look at look
look look look oh yeah go back go back
that's what I'm talking about guys
that's been punch-drunk all right what
do we tell are we doing our locks oh no
no no no let's go all hand signals from
now on yeah baby sign language we could
do that you're teaching your baby to
sign before you even talk well it's like
so they you know if they want more food
or stuff supposed to make it easier til
they talk we could just do that has she
done in and she picked up on any of it
she understands all done all done is
just okay oh my god you're raising a
cereal teacher this
legit too legit to quit I will but we
really do have to set up a fight baby
baby Barb and pay me imagine of my life
I could just go to fights all the time
because my daughter and be great yeah
how do we make this happen in the future
guys nobody knows I was just doing the
International symbol for baby [ __ ]
okay okay so this is Packers vs z Hawks
I mean I actually take Seahawks Annette
what is the spread I don't understand
how this okay oh wow it takes out take
Seahawks and nod I wouldn't call it my
locker week
Panthers Lions I wouldn't touch after
Panther scared me last week the way they
got beat scared you so much watching
Mary
[Laughter]
Cowboys Arizona ah-oh
Cowboys Falcons I wouldn't touch that
either well what is it
give them the line i mean- three I
wouldn't touch it regardless if it was
whatever list yeah I wouldn't touch
Falcons Cowboys both those seams are
like you never know who's going to show
me Houston just has turned it around
even though they're not even that great
but Washington sneakily in first place
you know so weird to Tennessee Houston
Colts they're all winning slowly it's
like this weird kind of Houston y
mmm-hmm I mean what's Colts record four
or five Jaguars Steelers oh that could
be a good one five and a half Steelers
that might be it I might take that right
now that's my lock of the week long of
the week which ones lock of the week
needs to be less than five minutes and
you guys are going over no we're not we
just started this oh my god
Cardinals versus Raiders who sucks more
that's that might be a baseball score
that might be five to three
oh dude this is a big game Chicago
versus Minnesota MN so lose that they're
done I mean they're 5 and 3x 4 so we'll
commit suicide and Ryan Mervis oh this
is such a good game and they wasted in
Mexico I don't think so I think that
makes it more exciting a hundred
thousand people there Kansas there's
gonna be just as to be a hundred
thousand Mexicans at that Stadium and
somehow there's still more
spanish-speaking people and if that was
at the Coliseum there'd be more people
speaking Spanish at the Coliseum I see
what you did then they will at what
Aztec Stadium whatever its cone yeah but
she that that could be a previous bowl
Chiefs Rams in Mexico Rams are favored
by are you know how not good these Rams
defense has been injuries bro I mean
they've been good at they just their
secondaries kind of been exposed Saints
Eagles eight and a half a lot of [ __ ]
points so but it's at New Orleans I'm
gonna take I'm gonna go with it here we
go there's my lock of the week Saints
Saints eight and a half points yes honey
what was the one right above this I
think that might be mine there who
charges Broncos I mean the Broncos are
garbage yeah
I'm gonna go Pittsburgh over
Jacksonville five and a half points for
Pittsburgh that's my bet TSI lock in the
week considered sucked consider it
sucked
are you in all in the basketball Zane no
anybody break you involve black people
that is an interracial porn anything
other than that no I don't watch any I
don't watch any sports anymore I used to
be big in a sports karate you like crime
thumb wrestling i watch fights i watch
UFC like i like highschool karate I just
see you just eating popcorn watching
highschool karate like ya might get rid
of boxing of Olympics is that crazy
no would you hear that I with you I
never know I know the other day like a
few weeks ago like this is what I knew
like I'm like okay I have to water down
when Sam says [ __ ] comes up to me bro
they got him finally got him I hope they
get Tom Hanks man he's been [ __ ] kids
Tom Hanks they got him he did they
gotten it I didn't say I waited up month
I waited a month still I don't know who
they are or what that'll mean that I
never said they got him but he does yeah
Fox about to get yourself yes yeah is
boxing itself removed from Tokyo you
know why cuz agents have tiny arms but
what you know they can't win the gold
why I get rid of it why LeBron has his
beats by dre on with his jersey on why
are they what would why they're about
getting rid of it I don't know I think
it's because is it - too dangerous of a
sport like this thing about bringing in
breakdancing poker they're gonna bring
poker another cup bring poker is break
dancing break dance like turbo and hos
alright dancing poker
oh it's cause of corruption can I can I
be as a corruption in an Olympic boxing
like they can't keep it clean and they
can't keep it legit because
points you're winning you're going off
of points what's always been horribly
corrupt it's the Olympics in general has
always been horribly corrupted in every
[ __ ] sport pole dancing I really
honestly believe pole dancing hosted by
Chris Hardwick
[Laughter]
pole dancing would be a good sport I
think so do those those ladies are legit
yeah my man's a pole dancer your friend
who in France what's his name
oh I think that is a guy no that's a
girl give me something that's what the
soccer ball
give me how much has it she's gonna make
it disappear if you know what I'm saying
[Laughter]
inside boner I'm party I'm so turned off
I'm already over amarty over this give
her the gold just pull dance stop with
the [ __ ] Sesame Street dance she's
teasing the pole yes I'm here comes look
at that dude that is amazing dude
amazing and you know I wonder if they
take it how many tips you make while
you're doing this I was at a strip club
for a bachelor party this August and
this woman it was a crazy strip club in
Portland and it's all about the pole
dancing like no one was getting lap
dances because all the strippers are so
amazing pole dancing this one woman
climbs at the top of the pole like in
the blink of an eye like a like a like a
little monkey and then and then she does
this walk this air walk like she's
walking downstairs in circles and
everyone in the club grabbed their money
and just threw it up in the air was so
exciting did you know the time I
stripped one time in my life I stripped
after college one time I was working
yeah and like there was like 20 guys in
the strip bar none of them were getting
dances girls were bitching so mean the
giant black bouncer named Malik I'm like
I told I told the DJ introduced us as
maverick and chocolate thunder right and
we went on stage and we started
stripping now we got down to her
underwear I was [ __ ] like taking my
shirt putting it between my crotch cuz
girls do that guys go Chris Oh like oh
my god were such savages so I did it
girls were throwing quarters and [ __ ]
bottles yeah
I made 50 bucks man as soon as I got
done offstage all the girl all the guys
grabbed a girl and got a lap dance so
like never forget never again it was
their personal 911 I was gonna be a
stripper I have so many questions no no
I didn't strip I was working after I
graduated college yeah I knew I wanted
to be a stand-up yeah but I'm like I
just want to give myself a little treat
so I got a job at a strip bar and I was
working at like security oh I did
everything okay
it was saluting stripping oh you saved
the night by going up to strip yeah even
better I was at a strip club in Mexico
and I saw this girl doing pole dancin
did she climb like all the way on top of
the pole right over the wall right back
into America ever go to like if you want
to brothel oh boy
you know those brothels in have you been
to one yeah Wow we went to that sex club
but we were working our mouths on Dixit
no but I've never been to it like a
buddy ranch kind of thing
now the Tijuana brothel the main ones
called Hong Kong it's four stories yes
literally thousands of men and hundreds
of strippers they're doing crazy dildo
sex shows the whole place is covered in
like soap foam girls are sliding around
when I go there and up there no there's
no fight down there
Randolph wanted me to do stamp that I
think we'll go down we'll do stand-up
you would be murdered they stab you I
know dude everyone's having so much fun
in there yeah we go up and do steal
bring Lamar Odom yeah just just think
about this cuz they were born on the
other side of this imaginary strip they
have to sell their vaginas to make money
no these aren't the girls that are at
that place that that's no that's really
Trans Am Ann I'm really sad about that
that girl looks you know yeah her Fox
has this great joke and he never tells
it and and
I was like dude I always remember that
one joke here's a guy I only told that a
couple times um he's like he doesn't
tell me more but he's like I was in
Tijuana and there was his girl there was
shooting ping pong balls out of her
vagina and he goes that's your voice of
I'm not listening while you're looking
at your laptop uh-huh that's interesting
no way why are you marry it boom got him
pull up my videos so Kurt Fox is like I
was in Tijuana and his girl was
shouldn't ping-pong balls out of her
vagina she took me two out of three sets
you just put a spin on it I couldn't
return their serve Tripoli what was that
strip club we went to back in your drug
days down in the valley do you know I'm
talking about know that in like the LA
Valley
yeah you took me to this crazy ass trip
with anything they didn't serve booze or
anything
Oh was it was it Sam's Hofbrau it was
like a that's like a knit by the airport
yeah no that's downtown dude its shape
you like horse ass ethnic chick so it
just looked like they pull plows then go
down there it's the best yeah I went to
the Spearmint Rhino Christmas party one
time Oh be back in that when I was
working at that sure place we did all of
their merch and my buddy who handled
that account was like dude trust me you
got to come with me just tell me where
we're going
trust but and through winter and it was
just like every stripper in Los Angeles
and every DJ in Los Angeles in a
warehouse I mean was just everything you
know ever you just look around
everywhere
it'd be like chicks finger banging over
here there's [ __ ] people [ __ ] over
there's like and you're just eating free
chicken like this is crazy
and what's her food spread like it was a
pretty goddamn good really yeah
Christmas party
you know porn ho daddy used to have
catering I used to have a great joke
about it
horn sets yeah they had caterers that
make sense man I had the joke was magic
only catering school I have the work of
porn set you're serving pigs in a
blanket and a movie called pigs in a
blanket
[Laughter]
well that being in zero [ __ ] no no I
should bring it back though
I can't have this rule that if you songs
not special or yeah as I stand on a
special you can redo it bring it back
I'm bringing back a classic right now
ain't no probing elion gay guys it's a
classic people talk about it's a classic
it is a classic it is a classic I'm
about 30 minutes into a new hour you
know show off but I just like I'm not
one of these guys like I gotta put out
Nuala I got I'm just not gonna do it
has anybody heard imagine you have how
shooter went yeah how did shooter go
yeah he I don't think they talked much
Ryan and are even that was like I mean
Ryan and Jeff even that was their thing
but it was like Star packed it was Dave
Attell yeah Michelle wolf but I mean
they were they did the table read yeah
and it was hilarious I imagine it was
funny I don't know anything else yeah
and Arielle put it out in three months
you know so so do you want to hear that
daddy's gonna do no but it's number 350
or whatever so whatever he's released I
don't know I just people want to hear it
so I know they have to wait for that
mm-hmm was it well was it a well-written
script of course no that's why it's a
like funny thing they just start
destroying the word document he wrote
when he was 20 yeah you know and he'd
never even done stand-up um but yet
probably yeah it's a real tragedy that
we didn't film the gay porn it's a real
tragedy for the best way he yelled at
that poor guy that works this week like
wasn't really huh he's already really
and he's like I'm not going back to the
show till I see it's delete it was like
okay Ari gets really Queenie when he
gets mad right oh yeah yeah definitely
very much so do you think is like when
he gets angry as [ __ ] just venus
flytraps
and just gets really [ __ ] like angry
i don't know
i one time he like he sent over and
showed me his ass and then i spread his
ass cheeks open and it was a [ __ ]
lighthouse and they're just have you
guys dated or his apartment yeah because
that was Jeff's favorite thing was just
like how he's like sentimental or he's
weird there's pictures having his
girlfriend and frames there's love notes
he's like I'm uncomfortable oh so our
he's like really in love yeah what he
still has sex with other women and does
she's done when she turns 30 and she's
28 so you know that's she literally has
400 days left it really likes it really
flies her everywhere there's love notes
and frames uh-huh she was out here right
Arie is Allah let me just tell you
something
I'm sorry artis the best example of when
you get something when you get to where
you've always wanted to be you calm down
cuz like la is like very much like
drowning right you're just oh oh this
town everyone everybody always like oh
la must be great this town can suck your
dick I mean it really good way you know
it's got a real tooth it really can
[ __ ] wear on you eat it like corn on
a cob Oh Ari has it best because LA if
you want to do LA perfectly you live
somewhere where you're happy and have a
regular life and then you come here four
or five months out of the year yeah
that's exactly the dream and it really
is the dream that's the dream is to be
here for four months and to be somewhere
that makes you happy for eight dude I
was watching this because my mom was
staying with me and she just watches
nothing about the HG channel it's just
gay guys selling [ __ ] real estate
that's that whole [ __ ] channel and
dude they were in Texas and the guys
like okay this is a five bedroom five
acre house a hundred and twenty thousand
I'm like what I know right now with a
metal difference my mom's mortgage is
$1,300 a month and she's got a pool
she's got four bedrooms a ranch-style
house in Tucson Arizona that is eight
that's not like if this room alone was
just an apartment like your bathrooms
over there figure it out no oven that's
how much it is to live in LA well that's
why got $1,200 is a shitty studio that's
why brenards moved to Ohio like he
showed me around his house he has four
bedrooms he's like dude I was paying
this for my apartment he has like a
downstairs he's got a fireplace in a
yard his games here to work
like we're saying yeah yeah like he's
got the life is back on Ohio fat yeah is
it coming I saw me not go dude I'm
telling you right now I know what you're
doing cuz he was eating ice cream I'm
like it's gonna walk with a shovel
you're gonna turn into me dude trust me
I've done it Joe do it okay you got a
hot wife don't ruin it we got here
Johnny the drug mule people male you
should yeah
tinfoil Hackett's the most though he
gets crazy stuff really yeah yeah
whenever we're at the Comedy Store cuz
they held him at a show it's Tuesday
like people come up with boxes a tinfoil
hat stuff do they really yeah I got
recognized from this podcast oh it's
pretty velvet yes yes okay all you girls
I can't hear us okay okay our audio is
dead we are lives you're giving out
gifts it's the your sponsor oh it it you
turn it like a lipstick how feminine
calm you turn it like a lipstick and you
get your scent going here's what does
one say your name on it
this one says my name this one's very
sorry so these are men you could use
this like as a sexual thing right Sam
yes why do I get men's cologne
Temari give it to give it to the baby
you're feeling sprayed in the baby's
eyes these are Christmas and Hanukkah
gifts I'm just like I don't know where
they
was very masculine dude this is great
I know no I mean not for a podcast or
audios off again is this the best worst
podcast of all time is there no audio is
there no audio I don't know I hear
myself okay so yeah ah Jason we gotta we
have we are we have mr. Jason yes you
have basically what six weeks left in
2018 right that sounds about right and
Johnny you're leaving soon when are you
back Johnny also you might not turn
message what when do you leave what
Thanksgiving okay we have to bang out
some of these bets we just have to sure
let's do it it's got to be set for let's
do it okay so I'm out of town till
Friday Saturday night I get back Sunday
we can do it Sunday night Sunday's
terrible for me okay Sunday nights bad
no I leave on we can do it tomorrow
night
what what's tomorrow night it's
Wednesday night I got a gig tomorrow
okay Sunday night Monday night we got to
pick one of these dude well we'll just
we'll figure out a date I can set it
Monday yeah but what if then it we can't
what if I can't do it then do it do it
you got to pick it Thursday next
Thursday next Thursday he'll be gone for
that Thanksgiving that's Thanksgiving
next Tuesday can we do next Tuesday okay
so next day Thanksgiving Thursday is
Thursday Wednesday so next Tuesday we
are doing the drag walk so Tuesday after
punch run well I'm just with the record
guys Happy Thanksgiving coming up what
about what about Oh
Monday night let's just do it why Duke
why can't we do it without Johnny then
because Johnny has to be there
yeah Johnny it's Monday night we're
gonna do next Monday
Knight done BAM a week from yesterday
week from yesterday alright alright
it's in the books so that's dumb what
else do I'm with then next Tuesday we're
gonna do two shot-caller we're gonna
bang that out and then we'll figure out
a time for him to do is whacking off
things well he doesn't even need to be
here for that
yeah just it'll just be you in here her
in here uh santori's gone yeah so what
are you jerking off what do you do I
just have to jerk off during the whole
episode so we're literally not even
gonna be live that show it's just gonna
be you guys are gonna be here no I have
to be on skype what looking at you guys
you'll be here on scare no no I don't
come in now you know I'ma be honest
computer yeah so you so next Tuesday on
that Tuesday I get electrocuted for two
two hours by the way I was talking to uh
I was talking to powers on your neck
thirty minutes on your balls no that's
not happening
I was talking to uh I was talking to
gene oh yeah from speed weed and he had
this like flashlight thing that's also a
Taser and he's [ __ ] he's like on his
arm I go what what's wrong with you
because I [ __ ] accidentally tased
myself like three hours ago and my
[ __ ] my whole left arm is completely
[ __ ] that's some tasing himself once
that sucks
I mean we're it's a shock call you're
not tasing me Brian [ __ ] I'm wearing a
shock collar yeah I'm gonna wear a shock
collar but as a goof we wrote or you can
just wear it on your balls in heaven on
your balls for two hours and then put it
in a thing and captain dip [ __ ] over
here guys no one's ever seen him pay off
one bat it's like no we're gonna tase
your balls for you our slide right there
I told I oh no bets so whoo oh here we
go every Bell every don't do that every
bet is completely filmed yeah
where's the five times you said you
loved black hawk no you said you did it
that's different that's different
you're saying nobody see me do it who's
others who saw those five dude I do that
stage oh I love all your bringing some
Oh
everybody even said I made love we're
done
oh you did know everybody did why does
this keep happening
everybody said stop you're just trying
to make [ __ ] up cuz you're the last guy
to pay off all your debts no I'm not
yeah you are
no I'm not saying I'm not yeah that's
not why I'm making it out of your crap
that's how I'm making [ __ ] up saying
thanks coming on are we calm down
what are you talking you know because
this game be done it's not a game I'm
doing it's it's [ __ ] game I'm doing
is a game you're doing no what's that
yes it is absolutely I paid off my debt
everybody agreed to it we're not saying
house we have a bet we're gonna pay off
how it gets extreme changed if it's if I
have to do it
like that thing where the shot-caller is
funny to me
yeah me getting my balls tasered for
[ __ ] to our it wasn't on the thing
and I'm letting you not do that I know
it was it was a joke that was for the
joke I mean that's what's what you're
doing you do it's fun presenter we
discussing here you're saying 30 minutes
you I get to taser balls I said or I
could chase your balls for 30 minutes
each two hours on the neck or 30 minutes
out of the balls now okay now I've given
you doubt did you're not giving me an
out I don't get it make these rules I um
so super excited one more time with the
find your album iTunes Spotify sign
Helberg live from rehab live from rehab
a white guy named Chad you can get it at
Chase Bank
org nasa.gov if people are watching on
the livestream
I'm doing a show - this Thursday at the
Sycamore tavern yes dude come on out
it's gonna be a burner how long you in
town for like till Thanksgiving okay but
your balls tasered did you move - yeah I
may be moving back I don't know I'm all
over the place yeah you are you seem
like you are all over yeah I just mean
in general Brody Stevens jessiemae
paluzzo Eleanor Kerrigan yeah Lieberman
Gareth Reynolds oh my god it's really
great when is this I want to go hello
Thursday the 15th get a sitter
bring the baby do you have those baby Oh
Jim Nord might be doing yeah Jim Norton
I did you really do you realize he's in
town you let me know cuz we take her to
the movies right yeah it's great really
how much uh the other two guys are band
$10 on Amazon and they last till there
for but you see them all of the time
like that Johnny's invented that is
smart yeah airplanes are good because
when we're what the baby headphones
that's like Tyrone ease baby had a
[ __ ] night Sean Payton drew brees his
baby had it at the Super Bowl you see
babies of those [ __ ] no she'll sleep
through anything with us she went like
airplanes are really good cuz anytime
like they talk right hey peg it scared a
lot to like if everybody said screaming
I got a football game or something you
got a she had him at a Red Sox game
honestly the most things woke her up was
we saw The Princess Bride it outdoor
movie and I woke her up more than
anything we've done and we didn't have
them yet so that's when we huh it scared
her the little creature isn't them I
like when to roni one and he's like
Bremen my baby
yeah yeah yeah that baby was just like
[ __ ] it
well guys it was a great show thanks
tune in next week we'll be gray
alright by the time I get to Arizona
shad you're banned
thank you guys doing it we'll see you
guys next guys thank you guys seriously
suck it